first and foremost I think it's about us
achieving something or overachieving
which I agree
if the context is the budget no doubt
about that I think the the clear
strategy and Alignment from Matthew
Benham the owner Phil Jazz Sports
director the dice taking a technical
director and me as a as the head coach
aligned with a good staff and good
players I think
um that strategy alignment is one thing
two uh and maybe even more important is
the culture we have created and maybe
I'm
in charge of that not maybe I am in
charge of that and it's all about Good
People good characters
but what they create together a bit of
Magic the staff and the players I think
that is key because my staff can push
the players too
90 performance but the last 10 percent
have to come from within the group as I
say to my players they have to create
that extra
determination willpower to always want
to become better
and the last bit but that's linked to
the strategy is group recruitment we
need good players in that can play but
also fit into to the culture I think
good players is is the the is the most
important thing I would say
I think have a good
group of Staff around you I think that's
key
so that's that's the two things that
need to be very very important then I
think
the ownership or the leadership above
because if that's not aligned it's also
an issue and then of course I have to to
play and a little bit
a role as well and I think
Clear Vision
consistent in messages
conscious consistent Behavior
every single day
um I think that's key